well hello storms hi if you were to be
invisible what is the first thing you
would do nothing nothing I wouldn't want
to be invisible I don't I know I think
it's being sneaky and I don't want to be
sneaky at all yeah I pass up on the
opportunity yeah is there anything good
do you think you could do being
invisible oh and the goodwill maybe of
course yes but I think if I'm doing
something great and if I'm being of
service I would want people to know that
it was me doing that thing so visible if
I could fly and do great things then
I'll take that opportunity I like it
what was the vibe like on set it was so
much fun people think that we're filming
a scary movie so everybody should be
walking on eggshells on set but yeah it
wasn't we were having so much fun and
Alice and me and Lizzie our big jokester
so don't think they would call cut we
would go back to laughing and talking
about food and fashion and even having
amazing intellectual conversations as
well no do you watch horror films or
thriller films you have a favorite I
tried to I'm getting more into like the
horror realm and I was young girls like
there's no way I'm watching that but
I've done don't let go another plum
house Universal film and like this one
I'm getting a little bit more
comfortable with being a part of them
and watching them and insidious was
great and the orphan and Annabelle and I
don't even know if people consider a
quiet place a horror film but that's
like at my top what was your reaction
watching this film cuz I know when you
make a film like this obviously it's not
scary on set but then when you watch it
and see the editing you're like oh my
good I hadn't watched it you haven't
it's not I've seen on Tuesday so
hopefully my reaction will be good but I
I think from everybody's reaction they
said that they were super scared so even
though I know what's going on I feel
like I'll be on the edge of
see and really be engulfed into what's
going on yeah I read that you signed on
for Suicide Squad are you excited I'm
very excited I love the first one and I
saw it like three times with my friend
so to be a part of the franchise now and
to be a part of them the family is
pretty cool and my role I can't say
anything about but it was awesome and
hopefully she'll come back in the future
suicide squads I like it
I was also seeing interest Elba's
daughter are you allowed to comment on
that or it's just a secret if the
secrets to T yes t little T time 2021 I
know it's such a long way away what
hopefully some more details will start
to come out yeah but it's a really fun
film awesome thank you for your time big
storm thanks to you
you